why do you think the animals are so
attractive to uh
I went to high school with a guy uh I
won't say his name but it was Clayton
and uh why do you know you know a
horse
which I know aggressive that's what I
said
I was like anybody could ride a horse
but to one
well imagine imagine telling your family
that not where you were
you know let's let's do a little role
play okay
what's up what's up sweetheart where you
been uh you know it was out well there's
a lot of places be more specific yeah
you know I thought there was there was
some defense needed to be mended so we
don't we don't have a fence David I was
building a section of it and uh
sweetheart you've been gone for an hour
and a half and normally you go out for
cheese
or a scratch ticket
why do you have horse come on your jeans
foreign